yeah but Superman doesn't need prep time
no because he's crazy strong and has
heat vision Frost oh my God everybody
should be flying Superman's gone crazy
he's attacking the world we all got to
get ready Wonder Woman you ready to go
yeah I'm ready to go like flash you're
ready to go yeah man I'm ready to go
what about you cyborg yeah man I'm gonna
go with The Watchtower everything's
gonna be okay what about you Batman wait
wait wait everyone Batman would not say
anything because he would go here's the
boss where I've already left
everybody wait now wait now y'all need
to give me like 10 minutes no no he
would go like this I'm not prep time
here's my anti-superman bag that'd be
Batman's answer Kryptonite ring rep time
nude photos of his wife that I can
blackmail him with Wow his Twitter
password